they are finally here the apple
air tags these have been rumored for
years at this point i feel like every
time there's an apple event we think
that they are going to be announced and
they haven't been
but they are finally here we've got them
in the studio to test out i'm so excited
about this because i lose a lot of stuff
i'm not happy about it but it's just who
i am
as a person and that's just
i've accepted that
they've got two different variations
right now that you can purchase on the
website you can get the one pack
for 29 or the four pack for 99. and
what's really cool about these is they
are fully customizable with emojis or
text
so you are able to do that when you
purchase them we've also got some
accessories we've got a loop
a leather loop and the leather key ring
let's open these up
set them up and let's chat about it
here's the box
it is a tiny little package
oh wow oh man this is so exciting
because it's been a while since there
has been sort of a new
product category for apple and this is
an all new
product
[Music]
hello so this is water and dust
resistant it has an ip67 rating which
means you can submerge it in about one
meter of water for about 30 minutes
i don't recommend doing that but just
know that you should be okay
it does have a replaceable battery this
should last you up to a year
and the battery is just one of those
cr2032 coin cell batteries so it should
be pretty easy just
to replace the battery after a year this
looks like those little collector pins
that you would get at disney i should
honestly wear this around just so i can
find myself
look at that beautiful apple logo
hey tyler you want to see this isn't it
cool oh it's very cute
it is very cute
we also have a four pack we also have
accessories
to get into
oh look at the four pack look there's
four in the four pack
four one two three four
look at that okay the customization
looks very very cool
i already have my customization picked
out i'm gonna be doing a skull a pig
a poo and an alien let's open up our
accessories now
first up we have our air loop tag air
loop tag air tag loop
it's all the same really oh
wow i am so into this yellow color
recently ever since
i saw the imac in that beautiful yellow
color
like this looks so good there's a little
snap right there
open that up pop in your air tag
close it up there's gonna be so many
cool third-party accessories with this
one of the things that i'm really
excited about with these air tags is the
endless possibility of third-party
accessories
this one is by dbrand and you can check
it out in the description link below a
huge thank you to dbrand for always
being so supportive of my channel
they made this airtag keyring attachment
that's fully customizable with a d brand
skin in the color of your choice
it'll come with both a keyring and a
lanyard attachment all for under 20.
i feel like one of the most common use
cases is putting air tags on keys so
this is a perfect slim
cost-effective accessory for it and then
this just snaps like that
it's cute this has a pretty snug fit
oh leather loop fancy
[Music]
so even though this is a leather like
these both kind of feel
very similar so i feel like if you are
not wanting a leather one like that's
totally fine because this one feels
almost the same obviously the difference
here is you have this really nice
stitching
this is a little bit higher quality but
this still is pretty
pretty substantial as well right next up
we've got the
leather key ring i can't even tell you
guys how many times i lose my keys like
i'll just be like looking for my keys
mostly because i know that they have a
sim card ejector on it and i'm always
needing one so not only will i be able
to find my keys but i'll always be able
to find a sim card ejector
oh this is very nice
look at that so it looks like this also
has a little snap
just like so i'm gonna put a blank one
on here
yeah that looks nice so one of the
things that makes these different than
other
tile trackers is this has access to the
entire find my network and what that
means is anybody who has
find my on their phone you're going to
be basically piggybacking off of
other people's phones and bluetooth to
be able to find your lost items now
something that's kind of cool is if i
lose i don't know like my jacket or my
purse or whatever and i mark that item
as lost
and then tyler is you know
wherever i left it he ends up seeing oh
my goodness there's a purse and he's
rummaging around
or there's one of these tags on there it
would send him a notification that would
say hey justine lost this it would take
you to a webpage
with either a phone number or a message
to anybody that finds it on a way to
contact
me to get me my lost item
back that's cool another thing that a
lot of people were saying on twitter is
they had a really big concern about
privacy this is not going to be giving
away your location
or the location of anybody's phone who
actually
was able to help you find your last item
all of that is encrypted and completely
stays private there are also concerns
about slipping one of these into
somebody's bag or attaching it to
something
and being able to track their
whereabouts so they had a few things to
kind of keep your mind at ease the first
thing
is if tyler was to slip this into my
backpack
tyler anytime this sensed some sort of
motion it would
make a sound it would also send a
notification to my phone saying that
there was a tag nearby that did not
belong to
me which is kind of cool because you can
just picture that sort of pop-up that
would come
up whenever you open up somebody else's
airpods next to your phone they're like
these are not your airpods i imagine
it's very similar to that
it's like yo there's a tag nearby it's
not yours so they definitely are
keeping that in mind because i feel like
that is a number one concern on anything
that has tracking capabilities
it's a combination of the find my
network and bluetooth that will help you
find your items and also if you have one
of the newer iphones with the u1 chip
enabled you'll be able to use precision
tracking this is pretty cool because you
could take your phone
and kind of walk around and it will
direct you right to your device now
something else
that kind of crossed my mind is how
incredible this is going to be for the
accessibility community and one of my
friends james rath
is making a video talking about how he's
going to be able to use these
as a legally blind person so i'm so
excited to see his video
he actually sent this little message for
us right here hi my name is james rath
i'm a documentary filmmaker
youtube creator and i was born legally
blind i like to share the perspective of
being visually impaired while
interacting with technology or
accessible experiences like traveling
one of my favorite things about the air
tags like most apple products it's
actually designed with accessibility in
mind that means that as a blind user i
can use to find my app and have
everything narrated to me
including the precision tracking so it
can give me sort of this
game of hot or cold or marco polo to
find my items
which as a blind person happens a lot i
never thought i'd say this but
thanks to the air tags i'm actually
looking forward to losing things
thank you for the video james you're the
best make sure you guys go check out his
channel and subscribe and also check out
his video and say that the ij army has
sent you
so now i think it's officially time to
set these up and get tracking
well i'm gonna go hide while tyler hides
these so that we can have a fun
little air tag scavenger hunt here you
go tyler
you ready i'll just leave them here
okay bye
[Music]
is it time let's do this
the items they're there let's go find
them
so i have a list of my items here so the
first one that i'm going to try to find
is the one that's labeled ewt so i'm
going to click on that it looks like it
popped up on the map i'm going to play
the sound
that's cheating that's what i want to do
okay so i feel like when you play the
sound it's kind of giving you like a
sense of where it's at
and then when you click into find nearby
oh
check this out this is cool okay so it's
13 feet away from me
i'm getting closer
it's it's to my left i don't know my
left and right
it's so close
oh look it says here
oh i found it
that's actually incredible oh it smells
so good
it smells like coffee we did that ewt
mine pocket now we're gonna try to find
this one
this is in my backpack let me see where
this looks like it might be
signal's weak it's weak
[Music]
oh 30 feet 24 20 night 18
we're so close is it under here i didn't
even see it
it matches oh this definitely has dog
pee
all over it now
it's been found oh this is fun
next up we're gonna try to find my bike
i hear it
[Music]
it's everywhere
there it is that's a
sneaky good hiding spot tyler
sneaky good
into the pocket i'm like making record
time
17 connection is weak it's behind me
it's on my right
it may be on a different level than you
it's nearby nearby
oh there it is
all right we have one more to find
it's weird because the sound is such a
weird like echoing sound that
wait a minute is this in my pocket
where is it
oh god it's right there
it's really accurate though because like
it kept saying that it was sort of right
here but then it's like no
it's right here here here it is
well i found them that was actually
really fun we need to do
a bigger scavenger hunt hmm
i've got some ideas so that was a quick
little scavenger hunt
and a nice demonstration of how these
would work if you're looking for
something around your house
one of the things that i haven't got a
chance to yet try is the lost mode so
when i do test that out i'll be sure to
either post it here or post it on
twitter on instagram so you guys can see
a demo of what that looks like but i'm
very
excited about these mostly just because
they are small compact and they work
perfectly in
the apple ecosystem tyler are you
surprised how quick i found them
like i think i did a pretty good job
yeah i mean your hiding spots were good
but like
i could have done better they were no
match though
for the air tags you guys are new here i
make a bunch of fun tech videos
and i would love for you guys to
subscribe if you're not subscribed
already hit the bell so you'll be
notified when i post new videos
and of course join our fun community in
the comments below
and with that i'll see you guys in the
next video i now need to go rename these
appropriately
and distribute them into all of my items
i'm gonna definitely put one on my bike
this matches my bike
do you do you lose your bike a lot
well no do you
i don't have a bike yeah you do
oh yeah
[Music]
you